bonsoir nous sommes le lundi 20 juin
vous regardez le 7 8 le journal merci de
nous retrouver pour cette nouvelle
édition comme chaque jour nous revenons
sur votre actualité locale entouré de
nos invités également des journalistes
de la rédaction tout de suite on
commence avec les titres à elancourt une
classe va ouvrir à la rentrée prochaine
pour accueillir cet enfant autiste en
partenariat avec l'association autisme
en yvelines c'est une première dans le
département nous y reviendrons
le parc dojo le zoologique de thoiry est
l'un des sites touristiques les plus
fréquentés d'île de france l'accueille
quatre cent mille visiteurs par an
son nouveau directeur général a tiré du
bief est l'invité de cette édition il
sera question de ses projets de ses
ambitions mais également des questions
de sécurité face aux menaces terrorisme
et la fête de la musique c'est mardi 21
juin nous vous parlerons des initiatives
organisées deux mains et de celles qui
ont déjà eu lieu à aiguillon pour la
patrie a anticipé l'événement coupe pour
commencer à faire la fête dès le week
end et les agriculteurs yvelinois se
sont mobilisés ce lundi matin ils sont
contre le projet de construction d'un
centre leclerc à égal lui et le font
savoir
dès 11 heures les syndicats agricoles
locaux de montfort l'amaury houdan et
mots ont organisé le blocage de la rn 12
comme vous voyez sur ces images ils
protestent contre le projet
d'implantation d'un centre leclerc sur
un terrain de 3000 mètres carrés vendus
par là sauf sauf rasset maga lui
l'installation à proximité de la
coopérative axéréal une implantation qui
les inquiètent selon eux elle mettrait à
mal l'agriculture locale et la
coopérative comme l'expliqué les
présidents de syndicats agricoles
d'houdan et de montfort à l'amour y
écouter le il s'est est au micro de
patrick jacques de dixmude ce matin si
on met une zone d'activité commerciale à
côté là ça sera un centre commercial
avec une cafétéria avec ave sous les
vents dominants les quêtes déchargement
des frigos et des camions qui vont
approvisionner le magasin c'est évident
que dans trois ans on est bon pour faire
nos la coopérative pour démontrer que
un centre commercial un centre
commercial à côté de nos structures
agricoles comme notre coopérative nous
créera des gros problèmes de circulation
de mise aux normes pour la coopérative
etc et dans au fil du temps à notre
coopérative devra devra disparaître
certainement c'est ce que nous créions
et suite de cette actualité dans
quelques jours ce sera le jeune le jeudi
23 juin aura lieu une commission
départementale d'aménagement commercial
qui décidera du devenir du projet et la
fin du pass navigo à tarif unique 70%
par mois c'est peut-être en question
c'est peut-être pour bientôt valérie
pécresse présidente de la région ile de
france demande au gouvernement de
débloquer des financements pour
maintenir ce tarif ce en quoi selon elle
il faudra augmenter l'abonnement pour
financer les transports en ile-de-france
en mettant en place par exemple une taxe
sur cet abonnement un problème qui en
impute directement à la gauche et
notamment à manuel valls c'est pour
alerter sur ce problème que la
présidente de la région ile-de france a
organisé aujourd'hui une table ronde sur
la viabilité du pass navigo à 70 euros
nous y reviendrons dans notre journal de
demain et parlons éducation à présent un
nouveau dispositif éducatif pour les
enfants autistes il était attendu depuis
longtemps dans les yvelines dès la
prochaine rentrée en septembre l'école
willy brandt d'elancourt accueillera une
e mais une unité d'enseignement maternel
pour les enfants autistes cet enfant
yvelinois de 3 ans seront ainsi pris en
charge les deux conventions relatives à
ce dispositif ont été signés ce vendredi
à elancourt explications dès septembre
prochain
cette classe accueillera sept nouveaux
élèves des petits yvelinois âgé de trois
ans est atteint d'autisme ou de troubles
envahissants du développement
cette unité d'enseignement maternel
autisme appelé em est une première dans
le département
une enseignante spécialisée expérimenté
s'occupera de cette classe j'attends
cette ouverture depuis depuis très très
longtemps
effectivement l'autisme c'est un
handicap qui a été très peu reconnu ces
dernières années deux qu'ils ont besoin
d'un espace de travail très restreint
individualisé avec très peu de stimuli
visuels et auditifs
donc il faut aménager l'espace de
manière à ce qu'ils puissent entrer dans
les apprentissages sans être perturbé
par tout ce qu'il ya autour
l'initiative est inscrite dans le
troisième plan autisme initie en 2013
les conventions relatives à cette
création ont été signés vendredi 17 juin
par le rectorat
l'association autisme en yvelines la
ville est l' agence régionale de santé
qui encadre ce dispositif
ces enfants vont bénéficier à la fois
d'une prise en charge par un enseignant
donc met à disposition par l'éducation
nationale mais également par des
personnels médicaux sociaux c'est à dire
donc un temps de psychiatres un temps de
psychologues 1 et du enfin trois
éducateurs trois équivalents temps plein
d'éducateurs un chef de service
l'appel à projet avait été lancé en fin
d'année 2015 le groupe scolaire willy
brandt d'elancourt a été choisi pour son
espace et son investissement dans le
numérique
reconnu pour faciliter l'accessibilité à
l'apprentissage de ses enfants
robot et tablettes devraient faire
partie des équipements pour montrent que
le numérique aussi peut améliorer la
compréhension améliorer le travail
scolaire l'apprentissage d'un enfant qui
comme comme saint thomas à
le repli sur soi à un problème ni soldes
donnant une chute dans les contextes
sociaux a acide un peu isolée du du
monde dont qui il s'agit de deux par ce
travail intellectuel différencier où ils
puissent treuil à son rythme lui est
propre risque que les outils numériques
vous permet de travailler votre propre
rythme le projet a été proposé par
l'association autisme en yvelines
l'association dispose d'un service
d'éducation spéciale et de soins à
domicile et connaît bien les
problématiques des enfants autistes
comme son président dont le fils est
atteint par la maladie
les places en établissements spécialisés
sont très rares donc là gros avantage de
gros intérêts de l'ue m
telle qu'on ouvre ici à elancourt sait
qu'on est capable d'intégrer très tôt
même quand le diagnostic est pas
entièrement posée
son enfant dans une classe d'inclusion
dans un école dans une école ordinaire
et ça c'est une chance inouïe 17 % des
élèves scolarisés cette année dans le
département sont atteints de troubles
envahissants du comportement d'autres
unités d'enseignements de ce type
devraient être créés une centaine
d'enfants heavy noix sans solution de
scolarisation attendent toujours d'être
pris en charge la commémoration pour le
66e anniversaire de l'appel du général
de gaulle prononcé le 10 juin 1940 a eu
lieu ce samedi de nombreuses communes
ont organisé une cérémonie à cette
occasion et guyancourt ce sont des élus
des membres d'associations des anciens
combattants mais aussi des habitants qui
se sont rassemblées devant le monument
aux morts de la ville une classe de cp
de l'école jean mermoz était aussi
présente les élèves ont chanté à cette
occasion le chant des partisans
cette cérémonie commémorative faisait
également écho au drame terroristes de
magnanville dans lequel deux
fonctionnaires de police ont perdu la
vie mais également aux attentats
terroristes survenus en novembre 2015
appareils écouter gilles lebreton
adjoint au maire de la citoyenneté il
était au micro de many pottier c'est
effectivement important qui est des
commémorations qui est des
rassemblements de personnel je pense que
une minute de silence en hommage à ce
qui a pu se passer est important
aujourd'hui on est c'est bien de que
chaque l'art se retrouvent dans cette
minute de silence et repenser à ce qu'il
a ce qu'il a pu vivre à l'époque s'il
s'il est encore là mais aussi sur les
événements récents de cette semaine et
les autres passé il ya quelques mois il
est temps à présent de passer à notre
entretien aujourd'hui nous allons parler
du groupe logic ii du parc zoologique de
thoiry avec le nouveau directeur général
du groupe cyril huvier on saura vous
bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors vous avez été nommé en
mai dernier et vous assurez une période
de transition à la tête du groupe
conjointement avec l'actuel dirigeant
olivier milices pour le remplacer fin
si ces visages alors pour rappel le parc
et le château de thoiry c'est le plus
grand parc zoologique de la région
parisienne le groupe exploite aussi
trois autres établissements le safari de
peaugres en ardèche le bestiaire vivant
du colombier dans la vienne et le zoo de
santa ignace you au portugal c'est je
prononce bien
alors bordeaux nous allons dans cet
entretien nous intéresser au parc donc
sont le plus simple le plus emblématique
et qui est située dans les yvelines
c'est difficile d'arriver dans cette
entreprise familiale parce qu'il est le
compte de la panouse qui a fondé son
père qui a également à ses enfants qui
travaillent non non non c'est pas
difficile au contraire au contraire
l'accueil a été absolument formidable de
la part de la famille fondatrice et je
travaille très étroitement avec eux et
notamment avec collombat de lapanouse
qui est directrice générale déléguée qui
est en charge de toute la partie
notamment zoologique dont je ne suis pas
un spécialiste donc nous travaillons
extrêmement étroitement et j'en suis
très heureux alors vous arrivez donc à
la prochaine de l'été là où il y avait
beaucoup donc des visiteurs qui sont
attendus vous avez déjà certainement
fait face à des premiers défis je pense
notamment à la sécurité car de nombreux
sites touristiques sont visés avec les
alertes intenta qu en est-il de thouars
et quand ça se passe vous alors à à
chaud ce qui se passe ça se passe bien
d'abord il ya pas il n'y a pas du tout
d'inquiétude
sur en provenance de nos visiteurs nous
sommes en liaison évidemment permanente
avec les autorités
avec le ministère l'intérieur l'est
effectivement il ya eu un certain nombre
de rumeurs dans la presse sur les
derniers événements mais en fait que ce
sont des choses qui remonte à 2011
donc aujourd'hui il n'y a pas à notre
connaissance c'est ne nous a pas été
rapportée par le ministère de
l'intérieur en tout cas les autorités
préfectorales et aucune menace sérieuse
sur le parc de thoiry
le parc reste effectivement un endroit
familial ouvert à tous dans la nature et
nous accueillons tout le monde avec
beaucoup de sérénité après évidemment
nous avons un certain nombre de mesures
de sécurité comme tout établissement
recevant du public
non il n'ya pas de n'y a pas de raison
et nous n'avons qu'une nous n'avons pas
du tout reçu de la part des autorités
aucune demande spécifique mais nous
sommes vigilants bien évidemment alors
votre nomination elle révèle la tête des
grandes ambitions de nouveaux projets
pour le groupe c'est pour ça qu'il a été
nominé
oui oui bien sûr alors c'est pour ça
c'est effectivement dans le cadre de
d'une deuxième étape de son
développement la famille effectivement
fondatrice a décidé de faire rentrer
donc au sein de son capital
donc un actionnaire qui est un fonds
d'investissement qui ont financé et je
suis donc suite à cette entrée donc dans
l'actionnariat je suis arrivé donc il ya
maintenant un mois pour accompagner
le parc dans un nouveau développement
futur puisque effectivement nous avons
de grandes ambitions
nous voulons donner une nouvelle étape
de développement et à échéance de 5 ans
6 ans faire de thoiry de nouveau une
très forte attraction touristique
voulait pas y prendre à ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire un petit peu plus
non pas à ce stade alors on travaille
beaucoup avec toutes les équipes on
travaille beaucoup on a quelques petites
idées effectivement
en tête on veut continuer sur l'adn de
thoiry et l'adn de thoiry c'est les
grands espaces c'est voir les animaux
maximum en liberté et s'est immergé le
visiteur au plus proche possible de la
vie naturelle donc c'est vraiment cette
expérience d'immersion que nous allons
continuer à développer malgré tout le
parc va très bien aujourd'hui et avec
des nouvelles animations pour cet été
notamment autour d'un fantastique
labyrinthe où il ya un certain nombre
d'énigmes et un parcours a à faire et
qui remporte pas mal de succès et puis
là nous avons nous sommes très fiers
d'avoir eu la naissance de notre petite
course nasa quartier qui était très
attendu qui était très attendue est donc
aujourd'hui elle sort elle est
formidable elle est vive
donc c'est une ourse à lunettes donc
c'est assez rare d'avoir eu ce genre de
naissance
ça sert à vous allez mettre peut-être
l'accent justement sur le développement
des espèces que je sais qu'il ya
beaucoup de bruit des changes qui se
font entre différents os sur une star
c'est quelque chose qui va être au coeur
du projet oui bien sûr bien sûr
absolument au coeur du projet nous avons
toute une équipe de vétérinaires de
soigneurs qui qui travaillent qui sont
des passionnés est dans notre rôle
effectivement de zone nous avons ce rôle
et cette mission de développer de
conserver un certain nombre d'espèces et
en ce qui concerne l'ours à lunettes
effectivement c'était un long procès ce
processus pour pouvoir donner naissance
à à 7 c'est cette petite ourse et nous
en sommes vraiment très fiers très
heureux et elle est absolument
absolument à croquer voilà il ya aussi
des nouveautés
alors il ya l'ours il ya le labyrinthe
et je pense notamment aux 6 à aaron le
var on nokia cette enquête at war il a
été désigné donc par vous par le parc
zoologique pour pronostiquer les
résultats des matchs de l'équipe de
france comptant la compétition en
partenariat avec france football c'était
votre initiative
oui absolument enfin on a essayé france
football qui nous a qui nous a
effectivement contacté en nous disant
est ce que vous auriez
un animal effectivement emblématique
alors comment on avait déjà utilisée
dans le passé il ya des ya deux ans
harangue le warrant sur ce petit petit
exercice est effectivement harangue le
warrant s'y prêtent volontiers
aujourd'hui c'est un petit peu nos tu
joues un petit peu notre star d'autant
plus que je crois que c'est vraiment
l'un des seuls animaux divine et heures
à avoir pronostiqué un match nul contre
l'albanie
alors il s'est trompé mais il fallait
quand même lui dire qu'un match de
football ça durait plus que 80 voilà est
en fait au bout de 90 minutes j'étais
quand même donc on était quand même très
très proche il n'était pas très très
loin et avoir raison il a été question
aussi notamment de faire un hôtel dans
parc de thoiry comme celle qui à beauval
est-ce que voilà c'est un projet concret
c'est quelque chose qu'on peut espérer
voir se réaliser
c'est quelque chose qu'on peut voir
effectivement espérer se réaliser ou i
c'est un projet concret il ya déjà un
permis de construire qui a été
effectivement déposé on est en train
aujourd'hui d'affiner tout ça mais c'est
sûr et certain qu'il ya un certain
nombre de projets d'hébergement comme
dans tous les parcs
aujourd'hui zoologique où les parcs de
loisirs ne peut pas y avoir une offre
complète en matière de parcs de loisirs
sans effectivement proposer des
hébergements et nous comptons bien
effectivement assez rapidement proposer
le parc de thoiry comment vraie
destination de oui quelque chose comme
ça voilà et mais on souhaite
effectivement que le parc de thoiry soit
une destination de week-end de loisirs
et donc avec un hébergement et de
l'événementiel est ce qu'on peut
imaginer d'autres offres des événements
un peu et qui vont dans cette direction
pour touahri a absolument absolument et
c'est probablement une des raisons pour
lesquelles effectivement on est venu me
chercher et que j'ai accepté avec joie
et motivation de devenir c'est que là
aussi c'est une des des nouvelles
tendances dans les dents longues dans
les parcs zoologiques ou les parcs de
loisirs c'est de créer un certain nombre
d'événements
pourquoi pour renouveler en permanence
alors effectivement l'offre pour
renouveler l'intérêt des visiteurs
donc on a pas mal de choses on va
proposez effectivement des choses
superbes que ce soit dans la journée
même également le soir parce que
effectivement on se pose plein de
questions et on peut se dire que le soir
c'est aussi extraordinaire de visiter un
zoo et une réserve une réserve comme
comme touahri donc bien sûr il y aura
des nouveautés et des événements donc
plein de nouveaux projets alors à
rangueil le var hanks à cette initiative
qui a été fait en partenariat avec
france football il n'ya la semaine
dernière il y avait un reportage qui a
été diffusé sur w9 dans le cadre
d'actions où l'on rentre jeunes
notamment
donc le zoo de thoiry vous voulez plus
vous ouvrir aux médias peut-être changer
un petit peu votre image également oui
bien que notre image soit soit soit très
bonne aujourd'hui mais effectivement
cette enquête de w9 était été
formidables parce que je crois que
effectivement elle a mis en valeur
d'abord effectivement nos animaux qui
sont un petit peu notre notre raison
d'être donc ça on a pu les voir donc on
a pu voir notamment notre couple d'ours
à lunettes et toutes les difficultés
qu'ils avaient pour pouvoir avoir un
petit tour c'est tout ce que l'on fait
effectivement nos vétérinaires nos
soigneurs pour qu'ils puissent en avoir
et puis effectivement la deuxième
vedette du parc c'est important c'est
toute notre équipe une équipe de
passionnés qui se dédie à leur métier
leur métier c'est à la fois les animaux
est à la fois l'accueil de visiteurs et
je dois avouer que cette équipe on la
voit travailler et on voit avec quelle
passion et quelle motivation ils peuvent
à la fois s'occuper des animaux
accueillir des visiteurs et c'est aussi
eux les stars 2 de thoiry c'est toute
cette équipe donc certainement connaître
plein de nouveaux projets dès la rentrée
à retrouver peut-être pas forcément cet
été alors c'est toujours un peu long de
faire dd des nouveautés donc
on est en train d'y réfléchir en tout
cas c'est certain pour la rentrée du
mois d'avril
ça c'est sûr parce que c'est souvent
beaucoup de choses un peu lourde à
construire parce que quand on fait venir
des animaux il faut pouvoir les
accueillir il faut construire des
maisons tu donc un petit peu
d'investissements lourds mais on a
pleins pleins d'idées ça c'est sûr et
qui vont se concrétiser à partir du mois
d'avril bien dessus foncé avec intérêt
merci beaucoup à tirer du gué si vous
voulez avoir plus d'informations sur
toile et si vous allez visiter ou
revisiter le parc n'hésitez pas à vous
rendre sur le site interne qui s'affiche
en bas de votre écran toutes les
informations vous les trouverez là bas
merci à vous forger et vendredi nous
fêtions la journée internationale de la
créativité l'université versailles saint
quentin accueillait pour l'occasion la
kraft party organisée par le groupe et
si cet événement a regroupé quatre
ateliers tenus par des créateurs et
qu'une loi est de proposer de partager
leur savoir faire avec et les visiteurs
et les étudiants un moyen de mettre en
avant l'artisanat yvelinois famille
bourdillon et mélanie poquet pour ce
reportage
précision concentration
les étudiants de l'université versailles
saint quentin ont quitté leur ordinateur
pour des perles de la céramique et des
bijoux pour cette journée international
de la créativité
le groupe m6 a mis en place la kraft
partie quatre tables accueillent un
public enthousiaste devant le travail
minutieux des créateurs chaque artiste
anime son propre atelier savez que c'est
intéressant de voir à la fois une
une technique on connaît tous parce
qu'on a plus ou moins tous fait ce genre
de petites choses à l'école mais qui
applique elle a vraiment des bijoux de
créateurs on se dit c'est très joli ses
fins mais derrière il ya quand même
beaucoup d'heures de travail
une manière de découvrir la patience
requise par ces professionnels et de
mettre en avant l'artisanat yvelinois on
voulait faire parler parler de du savoir
faire français de nos créateurs français
qui se donnent vraiment à fond pour des
cons faire des créations made in france
et on voulait bon vous partager avec le
public en général
cette créativité française je pense
qu'on a tous une envie de créer nos
propres mains et c'est une possibilité
aussi de donner envie aux jeunes de
découvrir l'artiste caché qu'il pourrait
avoir quelque part un moyen d'allier
plaisir et découverte dans un atelier
qui devrait revenir l'an prochain et la
fête de la musique c'est demain le 21
juin mais de nombreuses communes déjà
commencé les festivités ce week-end
elles ont pris l'avancé le cas de la
batterie de guyancourt une quinzaine de
groupes locaux ont été programmés pour
cette sixième édition l'éclectisme était
à nouveau le point fort de ce
rendez-vous un reportage signé fanny
bourdillon et mélanie poker
gospel métal ou encore jazz c'est dans
la diversité que la batterie de
guyancourt a fêté la musique avec un peu
d'avancé samedi une quinzaine de groupes
ont animé les quatre mille mètres carrés
du site entièrement dédié à la musique
faut savoir que c'est des groupes locaux
la plupart du temps du territoire qui se
présente à peu près une demi heure entre
une demi heure et 45 minutes et surtout
une diversité
on a aussi bien du classique que de la
chorale que du groupe musiques actuelles
jazz dans leur sélection valeur il est
demandé bien sûr d'avoir cette diversité
amateurs ou semi-professionnels ces
groupes se sont produits sur les
systèmes de la batterie dans une
ambiance chaleureuse malgré le mauvais
temps le tout premier concert on avait
un petit peu d'appréhension pour à peu
près pour tout le monde comme quand
c'est pour la première fois et ça fait
marcher j'ai trouvé ça très très bien
pour cette sixième édition le public est
une nouvelle fois répondu présent
l'occasion pour la salle de spectacles
de se faire connaître
seul moyen de découvrir le site c'est
vrai que la batterie
tout le monde connaît pas forcément le
site on fait ça chaque année et puis
d'autres villes et bien sûr des à 39 35
ans ses parents commencent à les
regarder certains habitués mais ça
ramène toujours du grand public et pour
ceux qui n'ont pas pu profiter de la
musique ce week end
séance de rattrapage demain soir à
versailles
la fête de la musique ce sera donc
officiellement ce mardi 21 juin pour
l'arrivée on laisse période de l'été
alors je vous propose un petit coup
d'oeil sur quelques-uns des rendez vous
proposés alors à monti le bretonneux
deux scènes seront installées au centre
sportif pierre de coubertin ensemble
saxophone chorale et musiques actuelles
seront au programme à voisins le
bretonneux comme chaque année c'est à
l'espace de covile que vous avez rendez
vous c'est là que se déroulera la fête
avec à 19 heures des choeurs amateurs et
dès 21h45 notamment du jazz du jazz il y
en aura aussi à magny les hameaux avec
apport aux ailes des chants des concerts
à partir de 15 heures
et puis aux clayes-sous-bois dès 19h45
le public est invité à assister à des
concerts sur une scène ouverte on espère
qu'il ne pleuvra pas sur le parvis de
l'espace à philippe noiret chiens et
enfin l'un des événements de cette fête
de la musique devait se dérouler à
versailles avec ouverture du domaine de
madame elisabeth mais malheureusement
cet événement est annulé à cause des
intempéries
on passe aux sports à présent ont joué
ce week-end la finale de la coupe des
yvelines de handball seniors au gymnase
des lavandières à saint germain en laye
l'équipe de plaisir à soulever le
trophée en battant montigny le
bretonneux 39 à 26
résumé du match avec un mickaël elle me
d'euros et camille l'envers la logique a
été respectée en finale de la coupe des
yvelines seniors au gymnase des
lavandières de saint germain les ce
dimanche 19 juin les jours de plaisir
qui évolue en prénationale ont battu
montigny-le-bretonneux une équipe de
division honneur régionale le score est
sans appel 39 à 26 début mars un peu
compliqué
défensivement on n'était pas présent
mais qu'on a un à plus défendre un peu
plus fort sur l'homme on a la plus jolie
remontée de balle les contre attaques
vous êtes venu faire l'écart en début de
deuxième mais pas seulement on a défendu
la vue du corps
des ballons
c'est de viser
uniquement alors
long du match pour les voiliers qui
mettait un peu d'intensité nous on reste
sur le même tempo
c'était important était plus force au
plan physique
à son plan des gabarits sur plan aussi
sur le plan foncier au niveau des
courses mes joueurs étaient fatigués
qu'eux
les heures de plaisir le match on savait
que ça allait être difficile mais très
belles choses de la part de
deux collectifs saignant devant qui dit
avec matt est logique
une victoire importante pour les
plaisirs oies les jaune et noir ont raté
la montée pour la deuxième année
consécutive en terminant à la deuxième
place de prénationale derrière paris
sport club
selon le staff et les joueurs cette
coupe dehimi une récompense leur saison
encourageant comme l'année dernière on a
fini deuxième du championnat donc pas de
monter mais à l'écouter divine pour se
réconforter quoi bon aller fêter ça et
là dessus on va chez le pivot la roma ce
numéro et on va retourner dans ma partie
prochain objectif pour plaisir l'année
prochaine conserver la coupe des
yvelines et enfin accrocher la montée en
nationale 3
et ce dimanche soir le complexe sportif
pierre de coubertin à montigny le
bretonneux s'est tranformée en fin de
zone pour l'euro 2016
le dernier match des phases de poules
pour l'équipe de france face à la suisse
a été diffusé sur écran géant
des dizaines de supporters et les
montants ont fait le déplacement
ambiance avec quelques amis lombaires et
nicolas landry de un bond en france en
un mois 2 0 pour la france 2 1 pour la
france 3 pour la france les supporters
ont cru à la victoire de la france pour
son dernier match de poule face à la
suisse ils sont venus en nombre au
complexe sportif pierre de coubertin de
montigny le bretonneux suivre la
rencontre sur écran géant et encourager
les bleus
ils ont eu l'occasion de vibrer dès la
première mi temps avec les tentatives
françaises
une belle première mi temps avec deux
deux poteaux quand même pour les bleus
donc confiante confiant ça va finir par
rentrer un petit peu déçue mais je suis
positif et je pense que 2011 va marquer
au retour des vestiaires les bleus
perdent la main sur le match
de l'impatience règne dans la salle
jusqu'à la rentrée de dimitri payet et
sa reprise de volée à la 77e minute sur
la transversale qui réveille le public
score final 0 à 0 les réactions après la
rencontre sont mitigés entre espoirs et
déceptions déçu ou déçu parce que très
normand côté baba on sait pas trop il ya
eu deux tirs sur la barre qui nous
réjouit un peu c'est tout il galère
contre la suisse mais après je me
demande qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire
kalman tessin parce que là si c'est pas
une qui conduit trop forte c'est pas mal
du tout surtout en première mi temps pas
mal de rythme un petit peu moins en
deuxième on a un peu plus subi mais
l'essentiel c'est de finir premier de la
poule et du coup c'est réussi avec le
match nul il suffisait d'un match nul
donc l'aventuré continue et on sera
derrière derrière les bleus pour le
prochain match et les prochains matches
la france termine première de son groupe
et les supporters pourront continuer à
encourager les bleus dimanche prochain
lors de leur huitième de finale et c'est
mercredi que nous connaîtrons le
prochain adversaire des bleus notamment
après les rencontres opposant la hongrie
et le portugal à la suède et la belgique
de rencontres diffuse également mercredi
au complexe sportif pierre de coubertin
à montigny le bretonneux chien c'est à
présent à la fin de cette édition je
vous remercie de nous avoir suivis tout
de suite vous avez rendez vous avec
michael me d'euros dans les études sport
je vous retrouve demain et vous souhaite
une excellente soirée